>> That's good, David. But here's something interesting to note.
It could have been that this was the input sentence and
that this frame representation got constructed from this input sentence. So
Haruto became the subject and the person and ate became the verb and
so on. Alternately, this could have been the frame representation and
perhaps the sentence which error gets through language generation from this
frame representation. So the frame representation could potentially act as
an intermediate representation for both sentence comprehension and for
sentence generation. Of course, there's a lot more to sentence generation and
to sentence comprehension than what we have shown so far.